لا ينضب الشوق والحنين لقريه اللجون
بالنسبه الى الشيخ زياد طميش
فهنا ولد وهنا ترك ذكريات لا تنسيها سنن
النكبه والتهجير مهما طالت كان زياد طفلا
في الخامسه من عمره يوم سقطت القريه
الواقعه جنوب حيفا بيد العصابات الصهيونيه
يوم اضاع والدته في تلك المحنه ان حمله
واحد من اخذت اخوي وانا مسكت بايدي وبلشت
تمشي معاي لحد ما في باب الدار ثلثه ايدي
منها او هي فلتتني وبالتالي نسيتني ومشت
طبعا
مين اللي سمعناه جارتنا عفيف الحمدان مرقه
سمعت صياحي ميلت على الدار شلفتني وصاحت
زياد وين امك قلت لها تركض مع الناس خايفه
طبعا حملتني
تلتحقنا بالمجموعه
في اليوم الذي تحيي فيه اسرائيل ذكرى
تاسيسها يخرج الاف الفلسطينيين داخل الخط
الاخضر للمشاركه في مسيره العوده
استقلالكم نكبتنا تقول شعارتهم جيل النكبه
وما بعدها يسيرون جنبا الى جنب تحت الرايه
الفلسطينيه الواحده في المسيره التي اصبحت
تقليدا سنويا
نؤكد للقاص والداني ان نحق العوده هو حق
شرعي وانساني وتاريخه لن نتنازل عنه ولا
باي شكل من الاشكال لن نقبل ايا يفاوض عن
حق العوده ايا كان
نكبه فلسطين عاما اخر ويكبر حلم العوده
ايضا يقول الفلسطينيون ان فقد الوطن امر
لا يدركه الا من عايش ماساه هذه الخساره
بجوانبها العاطفيه والانسانيه والوطنيه
وما زال يعاني من اثارها الى اليوم فقد
حصلت اسرائيل الفلسطينيين الباقين بعد
النكبه على ثلاثه في المئه من الارض فقط
وما زالت الى اليوم تتبع ضدهم سياسات
التهميش والتمييز على اساس عنصري
لعل ابرزها سياسه هدم المنازل حيث اصبح
ذلك مشهدا شبه يوميا في قراهم وبلداتهم
هناك
تغيير مع الفلسطيني في قضايا الارض قضايا
الارض والمسكن في الذات في النقب هناك
يعني ما زالت اسرائيل تحاول ان تصادر ما
تبقى من اراضي نتحدث عن 2% من الارض في
النقب اللي هي بملكيه فلسطينيه
وعدم قرى كامله تحضر اسرائيل على
الفلسطينيين المهجرين العوده الى قراهم
رغم انهم يسكنون اليوم على مرمى حجر منها
ورغم انهم اصبحوا مواطنين فيها كما تحظر
سكنهم في مئات التجمعات اليهوديه التي
اقيم بعضها على انقاض قراهم المدمره حيث
ترفض لجان قبول خاصه اسكانهم فيها بناء
على معايير فضفاضه لا يستثنى منها
الانتماء القومي والديني والثقافي ليسكر
راما الجزيره من قريه اللجون المهجره